hi I'm Cara Delevingne and I'm doing a
Google autocomplete interview so I am
interviewing myself never been done
before is Cara Delevingne in star wars
don't think so
maybe I'm r2d2 okay
it's out its kind of been vegan no but I
want to be vegetarian I'm trying to get
there so wish me luck is Cara Delevingne
modelling still sure if I have time this
card has been dating ASAP rocky know
that he's a lovely chap
it's Cara Delevingne related to Emma
Stone yes we are second cousins twice
removed the lie
how did Cara Delevingne became famous
how did card album come Victoria Secret
model I have no idea
not a Cara Delevingne and synth and some
meat christianmingle.com dress Cara
Delevingne
does does Cara Delevingne are to read no
discord don't even have an Instagram yes
I have four following Tesco delevingne
sing yes that's right
does Cara Delevingne have highlights
only my eyebrows how does Cara
Delevingne do her brows I don't do them
that's okay what is par delle Vigne
zodiac sign lion leo
what is card that'll be known for my big
second toe probably blue as well nothing
about me what's card I've been doing
what is Cara Delevingne tattoo I have
what that's really good questions what
year Dakar that'll be something I don't
know sorry who is Cara Delevingne
it's a question who is Cara Delevingne
best friend my dog here is Cara
Delevingne dad his name is Charles
olivine he's a great dad
best and the world
as cara delevingne engaged to my dog